hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today takes two stellar acting
careers and honors them by forcing
competition on unsuspecting art but
given the a-list thespians that we're
celebrating this afternoon i don't think
they'd shy away from a fun-spirited
contest after all one of them tussled
with mcu baddie killmonger only then to
be unwittingly tossed into the sunken
place and the other made it from the
mean streets of baltimore all the way to
piloting giant robots in the near future
everyone
listen up in case you still haven't
guessed who's appearing on this episode
of versus and you didn't look at the
title of the vid before watching it it's
daniel kahluya versus idris elba and if
this is your first time watching this
show versus daniel and idris uh they
couldn't make it here in person today
neither could anyone we've ever featured
on this show we're still asking though
right we're sending emails keep knocking
on doors in hollywood until one opens
you
shut up well if you are kauya or elba
now it's tinseltown that's banging down
your doors because every time a project
gets announced there's a good chance one
of these dudes is getting a phone call
but only one will emerge victorious on
this program which is why folks just
love watching it there's a winner and
there's another winner today i can't
call either one a loser in one corner
you have idris elba a guy who starred in
epic tv shows like the wire and in big
time films like those mcu talkies
sorry about that in the other corner
it's daniel kaluuya who starred in
groundbreaking movies like get out has
also appeared on the small screen in
revolutionary programs like black mirror
we'll toast the legacy of both
accomplished performers throughout the
show then it will be my thankless task
to crown one of victor but i still like
you both i
promise
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic moments round four tuxedos and
then we'll do a wild card round that
could be a challenge pertaining to
acting range characters voice over work
did you know that both daniel kaluya and
interselda have appeared as voices in
animated fair shut your tiny mouth now
even when they're not on screen they're
still raking in hundreds of millions of
dollars but they don't get to keep all
that bread but they probably get points
on the back end i don't know how movies
work from a payroll standpoint i'm just
happy that i get to show up to this
studio my key still works and the fast
food coupons they pay me with aren't yet
expired he did this by the book right
come on of course low expectations kids
it really comes in handy later in life
unless your name is daniel and or idris
then you can shoot for the moon because
you're already stars man i'm really good
solid good enough i'm not the worst i'll
take it and now we'll see how great
kahlua and elba are because it's just
about that time where i say let's get it
on all personnel that's the captain
brace for entry round one box office
highly trained actors are the subjects
today and all that practice and classes
and study is great but if no one sees
your movie did it ever happen at all
yeah no that's not going to be an issue
for idris elba because he's been in the
business for a couple decades and daniel
kaluya though considerably younger than
idris is off to a hot start thanks to a
landmark thriller directed by jordan
peele
get out was an instant smash when it
dropped back in 2017 the film would go
on to total 252 million dollars
worldwide which sounds all-encompassing
until you remember that both he and elba
have also participated in the universe
to marvel cinematique which is how we
really should be saying it
no kaluya stretches across the billion
dollar goal line with 2018's black
panther a film that would go on to gross
1.3 billion bucks before it was all said
and done that's a ton of money for
anyone even if you're idris elba and
you've had a flick that crossed the 2
billion line thanks avengers infinity
war
but elba isn't just relying on the mcu
to pump up his stats his voice-over work
sure does come in handy in a round about
cash made at the multiplex while kaluya
was great as the voice of the ghost of
christmas present in 2020's a christmas
carol there's no box office to show for
that but elba has a couple billion buck
earners in zootopia and finding dory and
he got close again with the jungle books
953 million dollar take oh that is a
good one
idris found more success with other
franchises like fast and furious in
which his hobbs and shaw took in 760
million dollars and both pacific rim and
prometheus earned more than 400 million
dollars on this planet
for kalia he's got one more film that
hauled in over a hundred million dollars
do you care to guess what it is
nope it's not judas and the black
messiah that made seven million dollars
sicario got close with 84 million bucks
kick ass 2 was solid with 63 million
okay this was a really hard question did
you know that johnny english reborn made
164 million dollars
please rowan atkinson we love him here
in the united states but he is beloved
in the uk and i do love me those johnny
english movies they spoofed james bond
who maybe someday could be played by
idris elba or even daniel kaluya yes yes
elba's not going to need any bond
gadgets to make out with a win in this
phase the might of the mcu is way too
strong but he may not even need thor
ragnarok's 850 million dollar take idris
also has sonic the hedgehog 2 with 398
million dollars star trek beyond at 335
million bucks an american gangster with
well over 200 million dollars and he's a
dc character too the suicide squad
grossed 167 million dollars i'm an
assassin
why would i share my liabilities
damn i knew he was talented in a bunch
of big movies but if the rock is
franchise viagra idris elba might be
siri cialis get those twin bathtubs
ready i am way better all told daniel
kahlua is off to a sterling start in his
box office career his films have already
totaled two billion dollars making for a
per movie average of 254 million dollars
and yet he still has a ways to go to
catch his competitor today idris elba
films have raked in 12.5 billion dollars
averaging out to a cool 337 million
dollars per project again the actors
don't get to keep it all but those two
talents are still worth every penny
idris elba gets the win in round one and
goes up one to nothing this is crazy
round two tomato meter slash audience
score well the good thing about the box
office round is that the more movies
you've appeared in the more dollars and
cents will add to your total but now
we're looking at the quality of the
movies in this section so the quantity
could be what's weighing you down
luckily for idris he's got lots of
flicks that have scored very well in the
tomato meter including some of those big
talking picture book films
the suicide squad is at 90 and thor
ragnarok is at 93 percent and those
aren't even his best marks in the tomato
meter nope those bragging rights go to
the 98
earned by zootopia and finding dory in
the jungle book are tied up at 94
percent infinity war arrested 85 percent
star trek beyond is at 86 percent and
the guy even rewards us for having a
netflix account they go the harder they
fall is at 88
elba also pops into avengers age of
ultron so we'll give him some credit for
the 76 percent it has in the veggie
patch they see everything but remember
when i warned you all that volume could
sink you in this round let's also not
forget that idris elba was one of the
many famous folks held down by
cats the napoleon of crime
it's way down there giving itself a
rotten tongue bath at 19
and suddenly looks like daniel kaluuya
has a prime opportunity in this round
because he was let me double check
not in cats
but black panther did feature him and
that's currently at 96 and that's only
his third best outing according to v8
judas and the black messiah is at 97 and
his current high mark has been
established by get out's 98
sicario has a 92 and widows is at 91 so
it's looking very promising for young
daniel here okay what is chat room
apparently it's a movie from 2010 and
it's at nine percent
e i don't want to think about that kick
ass 2 is at 32 and johnny english reborn
is at 38 come on i was just gushing
about rowan atkinson that whole
franchise is nothing but fresh for this
guy
[Music]
shot sir elba has more skeletons in his
closet including the unborn at 10
percent and the dark tower at 15 percent
so how we looking on the audience score
well sonic 2 is at 96 percent and beasts
of no nation and zootopia are both firm
at 92 percent but what this round may
come down to is the matchup we've all
been craving cats versus johnny english
reborn today we face the monsters that
are at our door you laugh but you'd see
that fight maybe a future versus episode
well according to the audience the
kitty's got claws and purse its way to
53
thank you swifties meanwhile reborn
improves somewhat but is still rotten at
45 percent fortunately for daniel kaluya
his rotten films are few and far between
and although widows fell all the way
down to 62 with the fans judas and the
black messiah continued to please
earning a 95 on this metric
when it's all said and done both actors
are tied on the audience score at a
fresh 66 percent but whereas elba is
knocked knocked knocking on fresh's door
with a 57 tomato meter average kaluya is
safely residing in fresh town with a 67
percent average per film for funsies the
wire is regarded as one of the greatest
tv shows ever and the tomato meter backs
that claim up within 97 percent however
daniel kaluya can play in this ballpark
too and his work featured in the fades
black mirror and watership down have all
been fresh according to both the tomato
meter and the audience it's enough to
get daniel w here in round two and we're
all tied up at one apiece
[Applause]
round three iconic moments okay so the
argument can be made thus far that
intercell but is only still in this
matchup because he's been a part of some
legendary ensembles like the mcu and
he's been a factor in gigantic
franchises like the fast and furious
well now the rubber really hits the road
because this round will be won not by
someone who's had a few good scenes in a
blockbuster but by who left the larger
impact in a film's most crucial moment
sometimes here at versus we do round
three focusing on the characters that a
person's played instead of the moments
they made but that's not fair here
because in pacific rim idris elba plays
a dude named stacker pentecost what
don't you ever touch me again
two
don't you ever touch me again that's it
game over that's the greatest name in
fiction or non-fiction
so while dr pentecost and his name may
not be able to help us out here a few
sequences in pacific rim do i'm ready to
run through a brick wall and start
punching kaiju after hearing pentecost
and his rousing pre-game pep talk it
might be the best rah-rah speech since
bill pullman grabbed the mic in
independence day
not bad elba also gets his most run in
the mcu with thor ragnarok becomes
frenemies by the end of the suicide
squad and is also note perfect trying to
navigate jessica chastain through legal
issues in mali's game but it doesn't
always end well for idris's characters
stringer well he could dominate any
scene he's in like when he and danette
have dinner but there's a reason why
they say omar coming yo come on you're
omar coming man
and an american gangster he's
wonderfully cocky as the new boss in
town but all that bravado quickly goes
away during a breakfast held by frank
lucas you're gonna shoot me frank don't
ask the questions that you don't want
the answers to you're gonna shoot me in
front of everybody for daniel kaluuya in
a relatively short time he's already
shown the acting diversity of an old pro
witness the black panthers versus the
crowns and judas and the black messiah
and the quote i am a revolutionary rift
put the film on every award voting
body's radar
then we arrive at get out the horrific
concept of the sunken place lives up to
its name but also look at the extremely
awkward and unsettling interaction that
chris has with the few black folks that
he can find on the armitage's property a
real doggone keeper
[Laughter]
the odd running in the middle of the
night the strain to make a teardrop fall
from a maid and chris's reaction to
these overzealous white people that seem
progressive on the outside is spot on
you know that whole movie is just one
long iconic moment i agree yeah queen
and slim showed his potential in a very
different role than get out the moment
at the gas station you don't look like a
killer is chill-inducing and i'd add the
wrapping scene in widows for further
range and kaluya can also get the most
out of smaller appearances like the
scene in sicario when there's bodies
discovered in the walls he also gets to
square off with killmonger and black
panther and it's a good reminder to
probably never accept gifts from a guy
named killmonger hey auntie but idris
elba also gets to play in the mcu
sandbox and even gets to blast off into
outer space as a sweet villain in star
trek beyond rock and roll features the
talk sequence and it's elba that gets to
blow up his ship and prometheus and you
know what since that movie came up
here's another friendly reminder to
astronauts that it's really not
advisable to hook up while in outer
space control yourself take a cold
shower glass of tang whatever it takes
just wait until you're back home on
earth the future of humanity thanks you
knock yourself out it's the tv world
where idris elba can start to pull away
from kawiya for every 15 million merits
moment from black mirror that daniel has
idris has a bushel of greatness not just
from the wire but also shows like luther
and even the office hey jim can i get a
um hi
hi
as the vp of the northeast his
appearance and face-offs with jim is
among the great moments in the history
of that beloved program michael handed
in his two-week notice did you also
handle it
no okay
and as an all-time mic drop i really
want to win this round moment idris elba
gets to have a lot of
fun with ghost rider in spirit of
vengeance
may god
lead you
into the eternal life if that isn't an
iconic moment i don't know what is and
it's good enough to push elba past
kaluya in round three and he reclaims
the lead two to one well done
round four tuxedos
yep vera wang makes those two i think
we'll check yeah and you know what
season it is when the james bond
clothing starts making the hollywood
rounds the award shows come in flying
from all angles starting around the
holidays and they culminate with the
super bowl of pretend the academy awards
but before we attend that gala and walk
the red carpet let's take a stroll down
memory lane
sure idis elbert grew up in the 70s and
80s in a working-class household in
great britain where at 19 he took after
his father and worked at an auto plant
he quickly realized that if he could
manage that job acting should be in his
wheelhouse as well so he set off for new
york and began hustling around town in
search of roles you know what we got
here
we got an elastic prodigy he booked just
enough to be able to work legally in the
united states and was able to officially
move to nyc in 1997 then he landed the
wire in 2001. daniel kalia grew up in
camden town london and was told by
teachers he needed an outlet for all of
his energy
so at nine years old he wrote a play
about two friends who work at mcdonald's
inspired by keenan and kell and their
good burger antics
at age 18 he was hired as one of the
youngest tv writers ever for the cult
hit skins and while most would agree his
big break was in get out for daniel he
credits a performance in the play sucker
punch at the royal court theater in 2010
that changed everything for him both
actors share a background that wasn't
easy and one that saw them work hard
just to create a few opportunities in
the entertainment world in which they
would take full advantage idris elba has
been nominated for five prime time emmys
including one year where he was up for
both his roles as luther and for playing
lenny in the big c he also has one
golden globe win for playing luther and
has been nominated for multiple baftas
as well but kaluya is one of bafta to go
along with an mtv movie award for get
out don't don't do that and then there's
that little oscar ceremony somehow idris
elba has alluded a nomination to this
point but that could happen any year now
kaluuya's already made quite a mark at
the annual ceremony as he was nominated
for best lead actor for playing chris in
get out he'd watched gary oldman accept
the statue that year but a few years
later he was back this time nominated
for best supporting actor for judas and
the black messiah and he took home the
statue the oscar sways me towards daniel
kalilla in this round but idris elba has
one achievement left to mention he's won
people's sexiest blake shelton of the
year i'm here to discuss that alice i
also think that with time daniel kalia
could grace the cover of that magazine
maybe sooner rather than later but he's
already done so much in his young career
he's been to the awards show mountaintop
and is poised to return again with
anything that he decides to say yes to
daniel kaluuya takes this round and the
match is once again tied two to two
let's go baby let's go let's go
and now it's time for the wild card
round eye for an eye okay well
technically we're not going to be
trading eyes or teeth here but we all
know the expression an eye for an eye a
tooth for a tooth well in this round the
eyes are going to be one movie from each
actor's filmography that best
exemplifies their greatness and we'll
couple that with the teeth which is
going to be a tv series or an episode
that best shows off their incredible
traits i can't say nothing to change
your minds now all these resumes and it
all boils down to one movie and a
program that could mean the win in the
most beloved of shows versus
hosted by me
i'm mark you're looking good out here
huh so there will be some suppositions
made by the adoring audience right now
as to which movies and shows i might
pick i will not be selecting pacific rim
for reasons that have already been
pointed out idris plays stacker
pentecost and it should be illegal to
have a name that cool today we are
cancelling the apocalypse but i also
wouldn't pick that for him because other
than the vince lombardi pre-game speech
he doesn't have nearly enough to do but
what's even more surprising i will not
be choosing the wire for idris elba on
the tv side of things cause you're
thinking man i know i know stop yelling
it's the greatest thing in the history
of great things it's inventing the wheel
number three discovering fire at two and
the wire's number one and there's a
thinking man right there but for all the
legend built around that show rightfully
so i'm rolling with luther because it's
the best showcase for the entirety of
greatness that is idris elba and his
movie i'm gonna go with the harder they
fall because i just saw it again loved
it just the same and he owns the screen
in virtually every scene he's in
the mcu stuff is great his black
superman line and hobbs and shaw is epic
and american gangster is one of those
rewatchable movies ever but again the
harder they fall just gives us so much
elba for kaluya i'm tempted to go with a
film for which he won an academy award
judas and the black messiah but i think
i'll go with my gut and choose get out
as for his tv i can't put one episode of
black mirror wonderfully terrifying
though it may be up against the whole
run of luther so instead let's do skins
because it might say more about daniel's
pre-natural abilities than any other
program he's appeared in remember not
only did daniel play a posh role on
skins at a time when in real life he was
middle class but he was also a writer on
the show
hello that screams volumes about his
talent that supersedes merely playing a
role but being the star of a show the
driving force the reason why we tune in
week after week that's the juice that
idris elba was bringing to luther for
almost a decade according to the rotten
tomatoes critics consensus for season
one of luther gritty and ambiguous
luther is a captivating drama bolstered
by a powerhouse performance from idris
elba in the title role it's what's not
on the page that gets me most about
luther he can know exactly who a killer
he's hunting is but then the
psychological head games start and
that's what separates this show from the
pack he's brilliant he's got a dark side
he can fall prey to temptation but it's
always an a plus performance from the
guy they call luther
i'm coming for you daniel kaluuya does
so much with his role as chris and get
out and one of the first jobs he has is
to make us feel completely at ease and
carefree about his relationship with his
girlfriend played by allison williams
now we're experiencing the events
through chris and as we get further
entrenched at the armitage's compound
we're getting more unnerved right
alongside our protagonist his
unexplainable run-ins with the staff the
awkward talking points presented by the
guests it's like the audience's heart
rate is beating as fast or as slow as
kaluyas at any given moment with the
harder they fall it's the tale of two
crews led by rival outlaws nat versus
rufus played by address elbow jonathan
majors is nat here's where the rufus is
getting out of prison so it's high time
to seek revenge wood ensues is a western
piece that allows plenty of room to see
the good the bad and the ugly when it
comes to rufus and also to enjoy a
rousing performance from elba and the
rest of the cast
please
if the harder they fall was never going
to be mentioned in the same breath as
get out that's okay luther will continue
to be regarded as quality television
that always had its star engaged even
amidst big time movie offers flying in
rumors of other blockbuster parts
featuring a martini milling around and
shorter seasons limiting the
storytelling angles skins should always
be earmarked as jump starting the career
of one of the best in the business today
but for carrying a show for almost a
decade and always being great even when
the character is breaking bad i'm gonna
lean towards experience in this deciding
round and give idris elba the win and
thus he takes the match you lose a
versus win might not be quite as
exciting as an mtv golden popcorn trophy
but getting a w over a talent like
daniel kaluya that's always a good day
kahlua's got plenty of time to continue
racking up the plum rolls award
nominations and possibly maybe people's
sexiest man of the year i guess i should
also point out that i have time to claim
that prize as well just consider me
editors i'll resend the head shots if
you need wow wow
but for today it was really just a
celebration of two greats in the world
of acting and it just so happened to go
idris way this time mainly because frank
lucas was nowhere to be found avoid that
guy at all costs trust me on this but
you never have to avoid us here on
verses hit me up on social media any
time at mark ellis live and make sure
you keep it right here on rotten
tomatoes for the latest in the world of
film tv and everything in between thanks
for watching i'm mark ellis and no that
name is not as good as stacker pentecost
[Music]
you